Here are three dead-simple ways you can
do market research as a copywriter. Tip
number one is Reddit threads. Find
subreddits in your niche category or
topic, and then look at the posts that
people are doing. What problems do they
have? What questions are they asking?
Figure out how your product can solve
those problems for them, and then
position your copy in that manner using
their own verbage. Second tip is YouTube
comments. Find videos in your relative
niche category, whatever it is, even
from competitors. Watch those videos,
and then look at the comments. What did
people like? What did they not like?
What do they wish they had more of? And
then take that and use it in your actual
copy. Tip number three is Amazon
reviews. Find books or anything like
that in your category or niche, and then
read the reviews, five stars and one
stars. What did they like? What did they
not like? What problems? Find the
reoccurring themes across all those
channels, write your copy that way.